saltwater under an electric current it's
a chemical process used to produce
important basic materials for industrial
use yeah here we break down brine using
electric current into sodium and
chlorine the process is called
electrolysis is over 90 electro loser
west of Hamburg is Europe's largest
chlorinated organics production plant
its main basic needs are salt and
electricity some 600 kilometers to the
south in Bavaria is another chemicals
industry company the detective family
dies impregnates and coats textiles
thank you should we make technical
products for all kinds of sectors
starting with solar protection textiles
everything for windows like shutter
slats or rolling shutters we make
technical textiles filtration textiles
and articles for protective vests both
companies face strong competition on
international markets and use a lot of
electricity but the chlorinated organics
plant near Hamburg has one big advantage
it doesn't have to share the costs of
Germany's change to renewable energies
so far it's been exempt from the
Renewable surcharge but Brussels
investigation into these reductions is
making the operator nervous young
husband is our total energy use is
greater than that of Hamburg not just
the individual households but everything
even industry the difference of paying
the Renewable surcharge or not here in
Germany is in the region of 400 million
euros and that's on a scale that would
endanger the entire basis of our
business the cessation of course and
automobiles two shifts won't loggins in
the
back to the textile finisher in the
south it has to pay the full electricity
costs because it doesn't use enough to
be exempt from the surcharge the company
says that's unfair and unconstitutional
and has filed a lawsuit basically you're
punished for saving energy you get
exempt when your energy use is a certain
percentage of your gross value at it if
you don't reach that level you don't
qualify we would have easily qualified
for it a few years ago with fourteen
percent of the gross value added but
we've had energy saving measures for
many years and now we're under ten
percent so for us an exemption is out of
the question now we have to keep saving
and could save ourselves to death the
presence of all public fun but
increasingly companies are opting not to
save energy in order to get the
exemption from the Renewable surcharge
there are two thousand seven hundred
companies this year alone but the EU may
put a stop to that if it's God surely
there are a few companies that don't
belong in that group they have to be
removed there needs to be general
fairness and that means the government
stepping in the eye starts going to the
US chemicals giant is watching the
situation in Germany very carefully part
of the electricity comes from dow's own
power plant next door another one is
being planned but in the long term the
company's investments are dependent on
the energy price and whether it will
remain exempt from the surcharge one
kind of infants are just invest the
investment we have here of 4 billion
euros doesn't make relocating easy doing
business in the market with a normal
competitive price is not possible
because you can no longer off your
product at a competitive price you have
to make a decision at some point you can
con getting Z unbundle a consequence
seen risen no one stays in a location
because it's such a nice place you can't
run your business then you have to take
appropriate steps like the consequences
you in Europe electricity is
considerably more expensive for industry
in Britain and Italy German
energy prices including surcharges are
roughly average in France electricity
costs industry less down look somewhat
wistfully at the neighboring stodden
nuclear power plant which produced the
needed amount of electricity but it was
taken offline ten years ago